i'm stuart varney i'm harris faulkner
i'm brian kilmeade and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday july 14 2021
i'm dave anthony it's a growing covid
debate
can companies or schools make the
vaccines
mandatory there's a big push for it and
against it
so if you believe that the mandatory
vaccination is not based on science
that is not reasonable you can challenge
it on that basis but
the courts have been highly deferential
in
the government's determination that a
vaccination is needed
i'm lisa brady two u.s presidents said
the end was coming in afghanistan but
now that it's happening
the speed is turning heads the uh rapid
departure of the us troops and the view
of many here
has got people concerned and in fact
that's considered a real reason why
we're seeing this uptick in fighting
between the taliban and afghan
government forces
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
160 million americans are fully
vaccinated
but nearly a third of adults have yet to
get a covet vaccine dose
on sunday biden advisor dr anthony fauci
said he's in favor of local mandates
telling abc's this week
viruses and public health don't know the
difference
between a democrat or republican with
rising cases in low vaccination rate
areas president biden caused controversy
last week saying
we need to knock on doors press
secretary jensachi
clarified this is not federal employees
going door-to-door
this is grassroots volunteers she also
said there will be no
federal vaccine mandate but many
republicans say enough
we need to stand up strong for the
liberties that protected us as americans
congressman chip roy tells fox it's our
duty as americans
our patriotic duty to make decisions for
ourselves that has led some
republican-led states
to pass or consider laws barring vaccine
passports
or mandates requiring the shots the cdc
has sweeping
authority to mandate conditions in
federal facilities
there's more of a controversy as to how
far that can
extend jonathan turley is a professor of
public interest law and a fox news
contributor
president trump and president biden both
have suggested that they could
dictate things to the states as to
mandating
vaccines or other types of conditions
that's not entirely clear i mean the
public health
was primarily left to the states
the courts tend to be very deferential
but there could come a point where
they could have difficulty on a
constitutional basis
what's clear is that the biden
administration does not want to mandate
the vaccine at the same time professor
my question i mean dr anthony fauci over
the weekend had said that
they would support though on a local or
a state level
a push to make this and mandate this and
a lot of this
is this issue is being played out on
those levels there are lawsuits and all
kinds of uh
laws being put on the books and states
that's right and i think that's the
preference
of the administration is to rely on the
states but particularly private
businesses we
we had a number of statements from the
white house signaling the private
businesses that they think it'd be a
good idea to mandate
proof of vaccination for movie theaters
restaurants and other types of
businesses
we also had a cnn analyst just two days
ago say
that we have to make life as difficult
as possible for anyone
who's not vaccinated to make this an
easier choice
so you're going to see a lot more of
this ramped up pressure
coming particularly from private sources
like morgan stanley just said that they
all their employees must be vaccinated
to work in the office
and you're going to see some states
moving in that direction
there are laws now in some states to
prevent
employers from doing that and in some
cases putting them
on the same level as protected classes
like people who are
protected by religion or something that
they cannot control
obviously you can control whether you're
vaccinated or not yes i think this is
part of the pushback
i mean when you look at the if you
actually crunch the numbers
you get an idea of why the
administration and
democratic leaders are pushing this
because despite
all of the media hammering away at the
need to get vaccinated
people are not doing it and so then now
you're beginning to hear
like this analyst say well we just need
to make life as hard as possible on
anyone who doesn't want to be vaccinated
and that's triggering these laws that
you're talking about that they
the response for some of these states is
not in this state
you know back up and take covet out of
the equation
i mean the equal employment opportunity
commission has guidelines
they have let employers set vaccine
mandates
for measles and mumps and various
diseases in the past
schools have not allowed students in for
having no vaccinations for some of those
diseases why is cova different
well it's not legally different if
employers like morgan stanley want to
require
vaccinated workers i think courts would
uphold it
they may have issues with people with
religious objections
that's where the more difficult cases
could come up but for most
employees uh they could be forced to be
vaccinated or have to give up their jobs
and even if they get an exception the
ceo and morgan stanley for example
clearly indicated you're not going to be
an employee in good standing
with them so they probably can do that
and in 1905
the court ruled in the jacobson case
that
massachusetts could require a
vaccination for smallpox the law said if
you didn't get a smallpox vaccine
you had to pay five dollars and the
court upheld that
five bucks wow what a difference 200 you
know 116 years makes as far as our
finances
but back to when it gets to
the workplace houston methodist hospital
they fired about 150 people
who refused to get the mandated
vaccine that was upheld in court
yes and i think that is what we're going
to be seeing
uh across the board i think that there
is clearly an ability of businesses to
stipulate that
also businesses unless there's a
contravailing law
in the state can probably bar people
from entering their business without
proof of vaccination
so that's why this is shifting over to
these laws saying we don't want
pandemic passports to be used in a given
state
so i think this fight is going to
increase because to some extent i think
the white house has been surprised by
the degree
of vaccination hesitancy
there's literally nothing the federal
government has not tried
to get people vaccinated short of a
mandatory vaccination
so this is a big political issue i mean
they're very close to a key
midterm election and i think the
democrats don't want to fight this until
just on the other side of 2022.
obviously there's strong rhetoric and
opinions on both sides but
some who claim that the vaccine mandates
go too far have likened this to nazi
experiments from the 1940s i mean that
seems uh a stretch yeah it is it's a
terrible stretch and it's an
an insult to people who were victimized
or their family is victimized during
that period
it's not the same thing we can have
disagreements as americans
about whether you should be forced to be
vaccinated i think there's good
arguments on both sides and i
i really believe that i mean there's
some people that look at this and they
say
we don't feel comfortable uh with our
family getting this
we're willing to take the risk on the
other hi at hand the government's
looking at the delta variant
and a number of other variants that
are really causing concern in places
heavily vaccinated
on tuesday a group of seven health care
organizations called on medical
facilities to make covet vaccines
mandatory for workers
a children's hospital of philadelphia
director upset that some people refuse
the shots
was quoted in the washington post saying
it is not your right as a citizen to
catch and transmit a possibly deadly
infection
professor turley's response well i don't
think it's it's a right
to be not vaccinated it's a right to be
able to follow your religion
uh there's some people have religious
objections also
you have a right to be free of arbitrary
government conduct so if you believe
that the mandatory vaccination
is not based on science that is not
reasonable you can challenge it on that
basis
but the courts have been highly
deferential in
the government's determination that a
vaccination is needed
are we going to get some sort of supreme
court case in a couple of years
that deals with this and sets rules or
standards or something
i expect the court would uphold most of
these vaccination requirements certainly
by private businesses
uh and by the states so it's not clear
they would accept
certiorari to accept review but the ones
to look for
those challenges based on religion and
what about the challenges that all
ultimately will come in the states that
are banning vaccine mandates or trying
to
yeah and on that that could be really
interesting and
i think that the states have the
advantage on that unless the cdc comes
out
and says we have to have mandated
vaccinations
uh then we could have a serious issue
here
but once states passed laws like that
then it takes a big dog to fight a big
dog and that means the federal
government
would have to come in and say we want to
preempt this
he mentioned president trump now we pick
professor turley's brain on the lawsuits
the now former president has filed
against social media companies claiming
he and other conservatives are being
censored there is
no better evidence that big tech is out
of control than the fact that they
banned the sitting president of the
united states
earlier this year democrats argue the
former president spread lies and
conspiracy theories and helped stoke the
deadly january capital attack
well first i should note that his lead
lawyer john cole is a very good lawyer
called me a number of times about this
lawsuit
and i talked to him about the
constitutional basis
in my view the president clearly has an
injury as do many other people
what the social media companies have
done here is wrong
this is they've engaged in raw
censorship they've engaged in highly
biased censorship they've essentially
taken
sides on political medical and social
controversies
so there's an injury there what's
missing is a real cause of action
i don't believe that the case will be
successful
not because they don't have a legitimate
gripe
but it's very hard for a court to get to
where they want it to go what they're
saying is that
because of section 230 that grants
immunity to these companies
and because of all the pressure
particularly from democrats for them to
engage in censorship
they have become that is the social
media companies
state actors that they're no longer
private companies they're
they're surrogates for the state and by
the way that is a perfectly
plausible narrative i happen to think
it's it's correct in a number of
respects there is coordination
going on uh you it's open you know there
have been senate hearings where senate
democrats
have pressed these ceos and said we need
you
to engage in what they call robust
content modification which is the
orwellian term uh used for uh
censorship the problem is that legally i
think a court would find it very hard
to say that uh that it's that they're
not state actors technically
so i i think the odds are stacked
against the president
all right so basically because they're
private companies they can
do what they wish correct ultimately
yeah the funny thing is that the
democrats have
opposed free speech for corporations you
know that was their
rallying cry was that citizens united is
such a terrible decision
when the supreme court said that
companies have free speech rights
but when it comes to social media
companies censoring
this material suddenly these same
members of congress are saying
oh well no corporations have free speech
rights
big tech of course has an army of
lawyers and they've been successful
fighting different lawsuits against them
including
recently a federal judge throwing out
attempts to go after facebook for being
like monopoly on social media so
they're pretty successful aren't they in
court they are and the monopoly
cases are the same problem they do
act like a monopoly the problem is that
they're a new type of monopoly they
don't
fit the classic definition of like a
standard oil
and i think we have to re-examine our
antitrust laws because
this is a dangerous thing it is very
dangerous
to have so much power held by google
apple twitter they're literally
controlling political debate in the
united states
and that should be a concern to everyone
jonathan turley fox news
contributor professor of public interest
law george washington university always
good to talk to you thanks for being
with us
my great pleasure thank you
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
the u.s withdrawal from afghanistan is
now more than 95
complete an updated estimate from u.s
central command on tuesday
just a day after the top u.s commander
in afghanistan general scott miller gave
up his post
passing the reins to the head of central
command marine general frank mckenzie
until the mission ends next month this
ceremony marks an important milestone
in the transition of our involvement in
afghanistan but it's not the end of the
story
it's rather the end of a chapter
mackenzie offering reassurance about the
u.s commitment to its afghan partners
even as security concerns rise along
with the amount of territory and border
crossings being seized by the taliban
the un's refugee agency is warning that
afghanistan is on the brink
of another humanitarian crisis with more
people forced to leave their homes this
year
and more civilians injured in fighting
conditions in afghanistan are not great
we've been here on the ground for
several days now and seeing reports
across the country
of the taliban militants clashing with
afghan troops
greg palcott senior foreign affairs
correspondent for fox news
is in kabul the common estimation right
now
is that the taliban has control of at
least a third of the country
and that they're contesting another
third that is a whole lot
so far the fighting has not entered in
full
fashion the capital of kabul where we
are right now
but there were scattered reports of
assassinations and an ied black which
left people dead so that's getting
people nervous here lisa
there had been a russian news agency
report about a statement from the
taliban's political office
saying that they're not attempting a
military takeover
of the country is anyone there buying
that
no no one really is uh we talked to a
leading politician
and uh she told me that the taliban
hasn't changed
and you can't trust the taliban with
anything there are no signs
that they are going to let up on the
fighting the only indications we're
getting
is that peace talks could be resuming
between the taliban
and the afghan government in doha that's
where they've been going on for
the last few months and in fact years
uh no sign that this could be any kind
of breakthrough
but if these are reports are correct
it could mean that the taliban is sort
of angling for position
diplomatically on the battlefield lisa
what about the afghan
capital kabul where you are is it fair
to say
that it's not what many americans might
expect
this city lisa has changed quite a bit
in the last
20 years when i was first here when the
taliban were running things it was
it was pretty backward but now since the
taliban has fallen
and there have been semi modern
governments here
there's been a real pickup in business
there's been a real pickup
in in construction and there is a
hectic scene of traffic here again uh
people
are all watching all of these reports of
fighting going on
around the capitol very very closely and
i've got to tell you and we've talked to
folks a lot in the last several days
they are very very nervous
in kabul though in the city um where
there isn't fighting
what is a typical day like i mean is it
just like any other city
where you know people are going to work
going home going to the store
they have a lot of freedom there there
is a lot of
traffic i can say that number one coming
from new york originally it reminds me a
little bit of
midtown manhattan but just a little bit
crazier
and people are going about their
business what we've been highlighting
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes